puzzle sales are soaring during the
pandemic as families try to stay busy at
home but until recently
the industry was missing a critical
piece see we did that omar villafranca
shows us how one brother and sister duo
decided to take action
after they discovered a lack of
representation in puzzles
it takes sharp attention to detail to
put together puzzles
something william jones and erica
chambers have been doing
since they were kids growing up in north
texas i really love to like look at the
detail of every piece
where you kind of see like the strokes
of the brush and there were a lot of
little pieces
every winter they tackled bigger
challenges
from 250 to 500 to
piece puzzles we're three years apart
and we
spend a lot of time you know with our
own friends doing our own thing and so
this was the thing that got us together
but even after all the tabs were
connected
they felt the puzzles were still missing
a piece
a lot of our puzzles that we ended up
picking were like cartoons like you know
we had a bart simpson and a mickey mouse
it wasn't like anything particularly
that represented us as a
you know as people of color that sparked
an idea which became
puzzles of color a small business they
started during the pandemic
corporate offices are in erica's garage
the pandemic has not paused their puzzle
production
just push it through here hit the little
green button
sometimes it sticks onto the board
pretty good whoa
and so there it is there you have a
puzzle puzzles of color
finds artwork depicting black culture
created by artists of color
and puts them on puzzles like kwanzaa
edward's painting titled
to be loved did you ever think
that your artwork would be part
of kind of a new expression for black
culture
when i saw the picture of it put
together i started squealing like
oh my god oh somebody actually put it
together and
enjoyed it it's really just rewarding
just knowing that
people can interact with it in a way
that is
different than just going to a gallery
or just seeing it online
daryl hill just bought one of the
puzzles for his three-year-old son
micah do you like doing puzzles why
daryl lets micah be a kid but feels it's
also important for his son to see
other people who look like him when he
plays
with the puzzle that i bought it it
looked like somebody that looks like him
you know
as he's growing up i need him to know
that he's represented
in culture erica and william are ramping
up production
and hope their small business can fill a
missing piece
in a bigger cultural puzzle it's all
about that representation
you don't feel like an other you feel
like you are part of
the world that you live in 500 to a
thousand pieces at a time yeah
exactly 500 pieces of culture
for cbs this morning omar villafranca
little elm texas
bravo eric and william give yourself a
round of applause you don't really think
about it
no when you're when i used to buy
puzzles all the time as a kid and you
don't think i
remember as a little girl the first time
i got a black doll i didn't want one
because i thought oh
it's different it's different yeah you
don't want to be the other and the fact
that they
are now showing uh puzzles of culture
what are they called puzzles of public
color puzzles of color
i think it's really so important i think
it's it's great that they're doing it
but
i love even more is the pictures are
awesome yes yes
on a different but related topic i
didn't know that's how you make puzzles
i don't know what i would have told you
but you put it through a machine and she
mixes them up before it goes of the
garage you go
brother and sister i like that eric and
william very very nice
you're watching cbs this morning i need
to get me one of them puzzles we'll be
right back